welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Jessica Clemens filling in for my boy
Eric boss while he's out on fraternity
leave and recently the directors of
across the spiderverse said in an
interview with total film there are
still Easter eggs being uncovered that
no one has found they even discuss how
they themselves are Easter eggs in the
movie and had no clue so I took this as
a challenge and here I'll be breaking
down across the spiderverse and
searching for those deep deep deep
hidden Easter eggs that Voss missed the
first time around and before we dive
into it be sure to check out nerd rot.
shop to get the latest and greatest in
new rockstars merch if you are looking
to something special for the nerd in
your life this holiday season be sure to
order you know couple days ago but you
can still get it and be like a belated
Christmas gift or a New Year's gift or a
Valentine's Day gift everybody wants
Christmas for Valentine's Day don't lie
grabbing some merch From Nerd riot. shop
is a great way to support the channel
and all the awesome work that we do
let's get into this after Peter dies in
Gwen's Universe the train she's on
speeds pass and reads train a couple of
times one's on the train at the
beginning and there's a ton of ads one
blatantly reads Green Goblin another
reads Maddie and the bitter glow this is
a reference to the VFX supervisor
Michael lasker's daughter who's also a
singer then we meet Gwen's dad George
Stacy who was inspired by how
distinctive Bert Lancaster's features
were and that is kind of crazy to me
because they do look exactly the same I
want to thank all the amazing designers
animators and Painters who shared their
work online giving all of us some
stunning scenes we might have missed
before like this scene at Gwen's dresser
closet and most of her room that was
designed by Tiffany lamb she used a lot
of her own personal memorabilia to
expand on the design but I really love
that the tapes on her shelf are the
other designers names that worked on the
movie Jake panion cat Sai will coiner
Jay ther Felicia Chen Dave BL Wendell
deit Khloe look and Steven Couture after
vulture's explosion behind the
ambulances you see ladder 3 members of
the FDNY ladder company 3 located in
Manhattan East Village were amongst the
first to respond to the World Trade
Center on 9/11 this could be a shout out
to them or just the latter company in
general then we meet the vulture Maro
belur who helped design the character
said the main inspiration for the
vulture came from Leonardo D venci his
codex atlanticus a more specific
detailed Easter egg call out than before
but in short yeah it's the classic Da
Vinci look they got super into vulture's
design piecing together the outfit and
his weaponry and I love seeing the notes
from the Spider-Man art book on
vulture's hidden backpack blades and
then witnessing Gwen later almost gets
dabbed by them I love just seeing the
artist pay such close attention to
what's possible for the vulture to even
create when vulture releases bombs we
see their schematics Jay ther designed
these and shared them on his Instagram
unfortunately the font is just too small
for me to even read I can't really make
it out but the bigger image and design
are pretty cool it's actually revealed
online through Jake's Instagram that the
lasers that Miguel uses on George
actually do have words running through
them it feels like the same kind of
design on Miguel's suit if you look at
the Reds very closely especially when
we're at Earth 928 Miguel's watch reads
Earth 65 which is Gwen's he opens it
pinning in the coordination to go back
to Earth 928 AKA his Universe at the top
of the watch however it reads 1610 and
138 1610 is Miles and hobes is 138 an
early test the design was to say
favorites now it says Destin ation
regardless this could imply that
Miguel's already been to Miles universe
or he's near it I like to think it's
amongst his favorites still though once
we get to Miles intro there's a lot of
shout outs to New York like flat Bush
but also this bus route the B7 bus from
Midwood I don't know the New York metro
line but damn did I ask my friends about
it we thp into Brooklyn and see a Fruit
Stand and some graffiti to the left this
was done by Chris O'Keefe he did some
remarkable beautiful graffiti work for
this film but this one says Steve
sweatpants with a disposable camera and
I assume this is the amazing
photographer for step John Irby AKA
Steve sweatpants Who can capture
literally anything and make it beautiful
he did an incredible photo essay called
41 to 99 go look it up this man's
remarkable the counselor's office or
above him is a flag that just reads
Panther could it be a call out to the
Black Panther because I don't think
their mascot is a panther it probably is
a call out to Black Panther I love
miles's Earth 1610 Universe style
because it has these like little
squiggles and lines everywhere the paint
Falls outside the lines and I just kind
of love it a mysterious Vault teaming
with danger and wonder has opened are
you ready to embark on this secret
journey to explore the relics and ruins
now Magic the Gathering is letting you
take on the role of legendary Explorer L
coft with their new secret lair
collaboration this secret lair drop is
awesome it's got fan favorite cards like
Shadow Spear and Academy ruins with Tomb
Raider inspired Art Plus an allnew
mechanically unique Laura Croft Tomb
Raider card this drop is available
exclusively through the secret layer
website it's got six cards total plus a
treasure token and even better the
secret lirer to Zoom Rider drop is
available now just click the link in the
description below and get yours today
the counselor's office according to Jay
was one of the first sets put into the
movie and he assisted in designing it
the end result isn't too far off I mean
there's no bowl of candy and the bear is
now hugging the clock on top of the
Shelf would love to know why they had
these minor changes but I guess it's in
the eyes of the beholder during the
basketball game there's a list of names
on the walls there a lot of the bfx team
designers are just friends of the
company Ryan tulok Xiao and Thomas celo
and many many more we have a massive
sign for black lives matter but also in
the bottom right we have mother Shuckers
a real place and this guy must be the
founder Moody Harney and the inspiration
for this Easter egg far right of the
bodega you can barely see it but the
graffiti art commemorates ODB the BEDA
was designed by Tiffany lamb and the
stuff you see is completely made up she
notes a lot of the things in the movie
work but the magazine rack which is full
of Spider-Man comics now I'm about to do
something I truly hate I I have to skip
around I only get to talk so much about
these Easter eggs I only get a little
bit of time ask for part two if you want
it cuz I have more but I'm going to
start jumping around the movie now
Christopher Ana said it took months
finding a way to mature mil's initial
design they studied High School photos
of basketball player kawh Leonard to
reference Miles when we're taking a
spot's apartment office it's good to
remind ourselves his life is in his work
which is why his house office is a mess
in EN shambles Tiffany also designed
spot's office and modeled it after her
father's office because he's an engineer
and I just think that's really sweet
these little details in Easter eggs are
so sweet when Gwen is falling down on
the right you see Shaka energy Cola
which might be this drink when miles is
saved by perit they plastic in his band
seizes it shapes to look like the
Spider-Man logo little details something
that went over my head according to the
Book prior's powers came from Magic he
actually gained his powers from a
mystical Shaman it's kind of like that
in the comics a little bit different I
thought it would have been completely
different from the comics when we're
introduced to Hobie we see a little
crying baby cop that's designer wend
theit's daughter the back of hobie's
jacket says fnsm for friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man so he does
actually like
labels then we're taking to Earth 928
and the Spider-Man headquarters when
building out 928 they used the long
tomorrow for inspiration the comic that
inspired like Blade Runner they said it
should be avangard and futuristic
Christopher Ana shared on Instagram all
the designs they did many were based on
their friends and some were pre-existing
unfortunately some made it to the Final
Cut and a lot of them didn't like this
image we saw 2211 but I don't think we
got the night we see the little stuffed
Spider-Man I think Amy Thompson painted
this one and we see the cyborg spider
that Wendell worked on bosc got most of
the villains I think we only just like
missed Hammerhead with his little Fedora
up against the wall but I also really
really love Amy Thompson's pirate Dr
Octopus design when lla shows off all
the Doc O when miles runs into spider
bite there's a couple of things I missed
or maybe just I don't know didn't think
too hard about according to the
Spider-Man art book Margot AKA spider
bite comes from a world where most of
the global population spends their
entire days as avatars in cyberspace in
this version of reality the virtual
world is riddled with crimes and Margot
has created an armored spidered powered
digital Avatar to fight crime in this
world I mean yeah you can assume but I
didn't assume all that Jake also gets
into this design on their Instagram
marking the details that like kind of
slide into the shot that we also kind of
get in the movie we see Venom's 2099
chess figher there was an original Dr
Octopus arm from defeated doc Ox across
the Multiverse and you can see the 2099
billain multiactor jaw what when miles
tether snaps you can see the Billboards
a little these Billboards I've only been
able to catch the middle one on the
right are by artist Mac Zaba I think he
actually added a lot of details to the
vehicles of newa York go look at his
Instagram when Peter B Parker puts May
down to bed with MJ you see two stuffed
animals in her crib and that's actually
a stuffed Doc O and Green Goblin so even
in her sleep she's fighting the bad guys
I love this I I love her and that's all
the time I have for today on this little
breakdown I have more details and a
little more Eggies but like just just
scam at me if you want them a lot of
these Easter eggs actually came out of
the art book for across the spiderverse
and there it goes reading winning
again we should all just read a book
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
Lulu Clemens follow new Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for my
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching I'll see you on the other
[Music]
side